Okay, this is a really tricky problem. But the answer is the last one right
here. Methianine or M, P or Proline, D or Aspartate, or S or Syrine. Now if
you had trouple getting this, let's walk through
it really quick. I can immediately get rid
of these first three answers over here for
one very important reason. We have one start
codon and it's Methanine. A ribosome is looking for that start codon
and if I read my mRNA ACA, no that's not it, CAG, no that's not it, AGA, no
that's not it, GAU, no that's not it, AUG, there it is, AUG. AUG's my
star codon. Right? That means I get a
Methionine. None of these start with Methionine. All
of these start with Threonine which is an
ACA. So, if you just start at the beginning,
you would have started with the Threonine and probably
gotten one of these three answers. This is the
one, I think if you end up going all the way to the very end, and the second
one, is if you might have noticed a stop
codon. ACAGAUGCCUGA stop, right? And some of you might
have stopped completely and just put TDA, or if you
stopped and then kept going, right, that would not have
been accurate, as we see over here. Is a better
example of why you wouldn't want to do that. We know
now that we want to start at AUG, okay, so now
we know the first one is Methionine, and because we
have a non-overlapping code, our next one is CCU. We
don't do UGC or GCC, the next codon is CCU.
Go over here. CCU is Proline, so we have a P. They all have a P. The next
one is GAU. GAU. Aspartate D, they all have
that. The next one would be UCA, UCA Syrine right here.
So the next one should be Syrine. They all have that. And then we get to UGA.
And you'll notice that UGA is one of
our special stop codons. This would tell the ribosome
to stop translating right here. And actually the
only one that stops is MPDS, this last one
right here. The other ones actually keep going.
ACC, ACC. Is Threanine, right? They actually thought that
they should drop in another amino acid and keep
on going. When you get to a stop codon,
you stop translating. From AUG to UGA, this would
be our actual code that gets turned into protein.